und
D-D-D-D-D-D-D
Irgendwie erinnere ich mich das an die Musik aus Bio Shok
Bio Shok so richtig schön deutsch ausgrund Bio
Vegan Shok
Dann die mit den Epic Sax Guy
Was machen wir an das da?
Bisschen Musik
Oh, die wollen es wieder erzählen wie toll das ist die fahr informatik ausbildung zu machen bei den
die
diddidi diddi diddi diddi diddi diddi diddi diddi
Chill music 2020 exzellent
No vocals
No vocals, please
Plitz
Oh, das ist, der chillt nicht einfach, das ist deep chill
Ich habe gesagt no vocals
Ich habe gesagt no vocals, das muss ich den epic sax guy laufen lassen, wenn der epic sax guy nicht reißt, dann reicht das mal, wenn alle Strecke reißen
Die
D